they give you these two points in terms
of the parameter T and then they give
you a whole bunch of um of trick
questions right well there's one way the
result is money so here we go to part
one sure that the equation of the
tangent here is and then make you do a
result okay now it's short it's shirt
and there were two months okay so
therefore I'm going to say knowing what
the equation of the tangent sorry keep
reading the travel up okay to get the
equation at the tangent I had points
what else do I need to add to the point
a gradient very good okay so if this is
the equation of parabola then the
equation of the derivative is just just
stated for me to X okay so right away
you know the great he will be routine
okay done so therefore I just go
straight to point radiant form so your Y
minus y1 equals M outside of X minus x1
okay it's a show question so do not
write the results straight from here
even if you can see it you have to
expand you absolutely have to expand it
I do not see that line I'm not giving
the second mark okay what so therefore
from there I now add and then there is
my result do you see how I line of
argument yeah yes so long as I see that
I like I guess my point is this line
might as well not be there that line
deserves nothing I need something in
here okay and if that's not a plus T
squared over there I think that's still
okay all right so this part one part two
it says using part one now maybe you
surrendered that mark because you're
like who's going to and they haven't
said hence or otherwise which is
somewhat cruel okay but let me show you
how easy it is okay so this part two now
just think just think this yeah like you
stop the power of using parent
parameters okay there's the parameter
right there is the parameter
well here's the parameter well I've just
changed the parameter B 1 minus T I've
just changed the time that's the whole
point you can get everything in terms of
parameter right so therefore I'm just
stating it it's 1 ma it's 2 times 1
minus T X minus 1 is 6 PI 3 a little
more involved
okay we're trying to find a point of
intersection where they calling it ah ah
there it is yeah okay we want to plan
the deduction of these two tangents it's
simple I have an equation here I've
gotten the equation here just equate so
I'm gonna do this now I will save you
writing out all of the expansions and
that kind of thing you're going to get
out at the end after all the fuel like
manipulation because this is an equation
in X in X right dot dot dot
I have McCallum one two three the fourth
line that I right after this is x equals
1/2 like I said it's a show question if
this result is known so these lines are
important but they're nothing unusual
you expand you collect like terms you
can do that okay if something is going
wrong and you haven't got this out which
you can see from the x coordinate is
what you're supposed to get there just
backtrack something is going wrong in
those three lines once you get this what
I do with that yeah I just have to
substitute it I say when x equals 1/2
now where shall I substituted into yeah
that's right because ah why is our birth
tangents
I can choose either of them no prizes
for guessing which is an easier choice I
was before
that's the first one right so I'm just
going to pop that in my mind is what
this one this one is simple enough ah 2t
times 1/2 minus T squared so that is
there there's the t minus T squared as
required
okay so I got my X I got my Y this part
three
nice leverage I'd like to gradients
dependence of my executor like T plus 1
minus T
a caracal incident it's not a
coincidence but it's also lucky because
in fact the grating here is Mukti I just
showed it the grading is 2t and the
gradient here is not 1 minus T it's 2
minus 2t
however because averaging oh well let's
get an average those right so you've
gone twice as five birth directions so
it could be luckily luckily you'll end
up exactly the same but it was lucky
well the method is yeah I wouldn't use
that it's not that hard to go that now
we're at the last point and this
requires some four so it is PI Paul
let's just read the question carefully
because they do give you some
substantial hints describe the locus of
our here's the locker Samoa as T varies
and then they put into big red flashing
lights stating any restriction on the Y
corner they even tell you it's a range
restriction okay got some senses it has
to be a rate restriction because look
here's where R is okay I just forget
about the white corner for a second the
x coordinate is always a huff the x
coordinate is always off so I could be
saying yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all of these have an x coordinate
or a half right so describe to me what
kind of shape have I just traced out
I've traced out a line it's a vertical
line because it has the equation x
equals a hug so I would here's how I
would write it on where ah loose along
because they've asked me to describe how
it moves as T varies right it moves
along the vertical line x equals a hump
right so that's really good that's the
first that's the first mark okay but
secondly there is a restriction because
the line x equals 1/2 it doesn't just go
down here it also the line it goes
through here as well but that's
a problem for me that second half of the
line that I just drew okay because
what's the geometric description of our
what defines it it's my two tangents
intersect okay I don't care what are you
drawing or tangents your tangents are
never going to insect intersect inside
yeah they certainly not kind of insect
you know they're not going to intersect
within the parabola right by definition
tangents stay outside the tunnel all
right that's what makes them tangents so
all of these guys are out of the running
okay so I need to be a little more fine
like I can't just say all of those
points I need to find out the
restriction on the range how do I do it
okay good so x equals 1/2 should if I
put it into the parabola tell me that
point right and that's the point where
it stops so therefore at that point
which because it's y equals x square
that point is going to be 1/2 okay at
that point the locker stops it's got to
be below there and not above okay so my
restriction or why I would say where Y
has to be now can it be equal to Y was a
corner
so you look at the question and the
question says the diagram shows two what
kind of points is the distinct point two
points that are not be at the same spot
okay the only way I could be right there
is on the parabola which is if my tennis
were the same line which they are not
okay they can't be so therefore 1/4 is
not included in the range